[Music]
so thank you very much for inviting me
and giving me this opportunity to
present some of our work this is a very
small portion of our work network and
imagine we do much much more and it was
really difficult to actually select the
topic because we could be speaking on
many things I have however modified the
title slightly it's actually I snuck in
cloudmesh multi-cloud interfaces because
this is a super relevant for the NIST
architecture and it's long term
projective into the future and my name
is actually gregor and i have a fairly
easy to pronounce last name but
difficult to write so I don't expect
that you've memorized us my last name is
actually phonetically pronounced as fun
la chefs key think about it as the large
F and ski law as the happy cook that
skis so you can really remember this
quite nicely or if you actually do look
up in google and type in the words
gregor and cloud or Gregor and cloudmesh
you will actually find me so this is an
easy way to locate me and one of the
things I did is I put here my email up
dress up as well as my home page which
is fully hosted on github so I utilize
that we have a manual for our cloudmesh
software that is part of this work you
can contribute to our efforts not just
the cloudmesh effort but also the nist
effort because i'm also a chair of of a
subgroup in that nest effort
you can certainly collaborate with us so
even if you don't contribute you still
can collaborate yourself and naturally
we are there for hire so
can contact us and we can do projects
with you together what do I want to talk
to you about today first I would like to
give you an introduction to the NIST Big
Data reference architecture this is not
only relevant for Python but for other
frameworks because NIST makes it a point
to not champion a particular technology
or programming language or framework but
tries to address things in a more
general framework in particularly I will
be talking about the volume eight which
I was an editor on and I'm happy to
announce that NIST last week has
accepted that volume as publication so
last week but it's not yet on the
website and so I will be putting up some
links and you can look them up late of
it's in the video that is being online
available to find out where this is but
NIST will update the volume aid one
thing that's was important to us is if
you're not only working together with
NIST to come up with a proposed document
as described stirrers but to actually
verify if what we are describing can
actually be implemented and utilized and
there are two parts to this the first is
the reference implementation that we do
as part of cloudmesh and the second part
is is how do we do the analytic services
on cloud mesh and we have at this time
only one service that actually showcase
that this does make sense here's a long
list of documents and pointers again you
will have access to these presentations
later on or can look on my web page and
these pointers will be made visible
there I would like to point out that the
first one is the working group from NIST
and there is currently an outdated
volume up there for for for us but they
will be updated within the next months
and if you already want to look at the
new volumes just take a look at my
cloudmesh github that I Oh website they
the NIST repository that does have the
PDF and since we are working with
generation Z students that also and and
esteemed colleagues that only travel
this iPads we also have thought ahead of
time and put epub publications down so
you can download them right on your
iPads and tablets to read them there the
evolving documents is really important
is this we I have a fairly large amount
of number of documentation so on the
order of 1,000 pages or so if you want
to teach some people Python and cloud
computing so you can leverage that and
they're all freely available and you can
invite me to your companies and I can
give talks I would like to acknowledge
support from NSF from NIST Indiana
University and actually I would like to
also acknowledge myself I should be
putting my family there too because I do
a lot of these things in my free time
and I'm not getting actually paid for
what I sometimes do let's jump directly
to the NIST Big Data reference
architecture documents this is a
document series that introduces people
from industry academia and other
communities to big data and what it
would take to define a reference
architecture so that others could be
implementing them within their companies
or within their educational frameworks
as part of this we need to be a first
identifying what are the definitions to
Big Data and and those things so we have
a full volume dedicated to definitions
we have another volume dedicated to the
taxonomy for big data which I will not
be having the time to introduce today
then we have a fairly large volume about
use cases and you can contribute these
use cases also to NIST as
contributors and these use cases are
also being now moved in into other
standards bodies and they have accepted
those as part of that effort the volume
six describes the actual big data
architecture and I will be showcasing
only one single slide from that
particular document which is the
architecture picture we address security
and privacy concerns and then the rest
of the time I will be spending on volume
eight which is the reference
architecture and that has actually
pretty big implement a implication
because we couldn't just publish the
standards without testing out if this
thing actually does work so that's
that's really important now that means
that the volume aid the interfaces gets
input from all these other volumes so
it's a lot of work to go through these
volumes and make sure that they are
consistent and work with each other
but there is an additional thing that
goes beyond what NIST is doing that's
the cloud mesh reference architecture in
a matter of fact this reference
architecture has also been deployed as
part of one of the largest
supercomputing educational resources in
the United States which is in San Diego
and we do on that particular cloud
cluster on demand so while we
integrating for example in slurm virtual
machine hosting in google or whatever
other things you do but on this
particular cluster we actually deploy an
entire virtual machine set as a cluster
for you and you have full access to a
virtual cluster and you can utilize that
so that's very different from OpenStack
and other things which do not leverage
for example existing queuing systems
such as Slom this makes it possible that
we can do on-demand scheduling off for
example of virtual cluster for someone
if he has a biology experiment or so and
I developed with my colleagues together
the client interface it because as we
saw from the Jupiter example that we had
here earlier
it's impossible for other people to
memorize what needs to be done in order
to put these things so our command to
start up a cluster is this start up a
cluster so and then you get a cluster
you have a parameter missus number of
nodes start up a cluster with 50 nodes
and then you get a cluster with 50 nodes
so let's skip directly to the volume 6
that introduces in this big data
reference architecture what we have
discussed with a group of I don't know
40 or so people mostly industry how they
would approach for example an
architecture that addresses big data to
be implemented on their infrastructure
so we have on the bottom
for example big data framework provider
that may be providing a batch queue and
interactive queue or streaming Q we have
platforms such as for example index
storage or file systems and then we have
on the lowest level the infrastructure
the services that's we are traditionally
coming from where we have virtual
resources and physical resources
necessarily we need to communicate
between these components was messaging
and need to be also integrating
strategies for resource management all
this is embedded on a security and
privacy framework and Fryeburg so that
you can make decisions about ok do I
want to expose this to someone or do I
not want to expose this to someone and
you can essentially pick and choose from
this and that is embedded again in the
framework in the management framework on
the top layer we have big data
applications that utilize this
particular data big data framework from
providers and as you can see is there
multiple slices that means we have
multiple providers that's not just one
provider but there could be multiple
providers that do this and we have also
multiple big data applications that pick
and choose whatever they need to do
in order to figure out what their
particular application requires so one
of the things that we actually have have
have done is is we have developed in
volume aid our interface to this
particular graphical a picture that I
architecture picture that I put out and
we have introduced things such as
identity data virtual clusters which are
clusters really important to us this is
you know nowadays you just use
kubernetes in many cases or docker swarm
but when we started this effort like of
like five years ago these systems did
not they well project this thing and so
we came up with the I think we're the
first group who came up actually was it
there's a term virtual cluster and comet
is an attribute to that particular
implementation we naturally want to also
represent infrastructure as a service
compute services containers deployments
MapReduce micro services and others such
as for example at the analytics
frameworks and pipelines that we would
like to specify one of the powers is is
I have worked previously in a standard
body and we had the issue that the
contributions from the community came in
so rapidly that the modification of the
document a document took months to do
and this was also the case here so what
I actually came up with this is this is
I developed a framework that actually
takes the specification from the
document and delivers the implementation
out of the specification document so
this way we can do it specification and
then immediately test of specification
out and see if this is something that
could be utilized I wish I could could
spend more time on this but this so this
is just for me I I did that it's not not
something formal but this has been super
time-saving one of the things we need to
be thinking about what's the scope of
this document we have established
operational interfaces we describe how
they are being defined so that other
people can recreate
this and put their own back-end
frameworks into this and we can actually
set interfaces through examples as part
of the definition of such documents the
content is really done through a
formalization of the info interfaces
that is being specified in open API 3.0
and I'm is anybody here aware of open
API if you could just quickly raise your
hand none okay that's a surprise one one
person okay so as a surprise to me it
allows us to specify interfaces in an
very formal fashion while we don't have
to buy ourselves in into supporting just
Python we can take the open API
specification and derive 3240
programming languages out of it because
we are using a generalized framework and
this is what NIST actually has
approached me with when they started
this effort they attained no I do I do
stuff like this and what we can actually
do is we can take that specification and
through community tools that are being
developed by other people we can develop
a go interface a c-sharp and C Python a
Java interface from that same
specification deriving then services
that are running in that particular
language so if you shop this doing Java
and you would be exporting this to Java
if your shop is doing Python you would
be doing this to Python so one of the
things that we have done this is is we
have actually used our expertise from
the development of cloudmesh and I have
to mention to use is I'm actually very
very little known in the community
however or in the cloud community
however this particular tool was the
very first multi-cloud interface ever so
we so even if you talk about terraform
and all kinds of other things we have
done this five years before they even
started thinking about this doesn't mean
that my code is
than theirs because they have financial
backing from companies I don't I'm just
doing this as a as a silly academic in
the springtime and so one of the things
that we that we actually do have is we
have interfaces to go to Amazon a zoo or
Google and Oracle and right now we are
in the face of re-implementing some of
these interfaces to make them better so
that they can also be utilized by
anybody and this is where you can
collaborate if you want to contribute
your interfaces you can actually do this
with us and we can put your cloud in
there into the into the framework one of
the things is is we are using the rest
and I will talk a little bit about rest
interfaces and why we are using them and
but they are not required as part of the
standard that we are pushing forward we
have a number of objects this is an
initial set of objects that we put in to
place to get some thought about what
what should be included in such a
documents for example and this this
thing can naturally grow if we were to
for example put the analytics framework
in there so we see then we have things
like k-means or SVM and so forth popping
up that could be integrated but we
haven't done that because we need to be
releasing the document so that the
community can can contribute to them and
can do the next step one of the things
is I already alluded to is this is I
have developed a pipeline to get from
the specification directly to an
implementation because we using a
specification that is using OPI the open
API and then we can directly derive the
web services out of it and so when we
make modifications to the specification
that spits out new web services so we
have everything hosted in github where
the specification is they are formulated
as a document in the source and we can
generate PDF and epub and then we take
the specification and use that
particular specification and open API
read the schema and produce rest
services that we can utilize I do
everything in Python but that doesn't
mean that you couldn't do this in any
other language so we do everything an
open API and
open API is somewhat simple to
understand however it's a little bit
more formalized and so when you as a
person look at open API stop thinking
okay I know I have to spend now 50 hours
learning that I don't have the time for
this so but it's actually really simple
once you get a hold of this and open API
is one of the community best practices
that is being employed to develop for
example rest services as far as I can
see however I learned no different
because you guys are all from industry
and so I I see the best practice is
different so I need to learn from you
how you do this and we discussed maybe
we set up at one point a survey so that
we can figure out how for example I can
modify my strategy or the classes to
address for example your needs within
your companies so what's the rest you
problem I guess everybody knows what
rest is so I will not actually say much
much about this but the one thing is is
we have to recognize that this is not a
standard and when we use rest in our
specification we don't actually use this
as a specification as a standard but as
an example on how do you formulate for
example in API or an interface so the
specification doesn't say you have to do
it in rest this is just one of its
implication that you can do it if you
want to open API comes with a bunch of
blocks it's actually a llamó document or
a JSON document and there are things
like an information how do you specify a
server do you do security how do you
pass and how do you specify the
components and I run right now into a
more detailed information about this is
I've decided to showcase you how do you
for example develop a rest service that
that uses open api to return the cpu
info from your particular computer this
is actually put an interesting example
because it's a dynamic example
and when we are talking about data and
big data it's not enough to look up in a
database that is being updated but in
many times you actually have to
interface with streaming services that
are producing data live at that time
when you invoke the service and so this
is a placeholder for that everybody
showcases you typically databases but we
need to be thinking beyond databases
when we are talking about life updates
so here's a llamó specification that for
example says okay this is the beginning
of the document and I host my thing on
the server as you saw from our earlier
examples you know people need to be
reminded where do I actually put in what
do I put it into my browser and that's
basically your reminder about what you
need to be putting in into your browser
then we need to be specifying the path
for the rest interfaces such as for
example what's a get method and you
probably all know what a get method is
and when you look at this particular
code we just do some documentation we
have a summary we have a response to
that particular get message
what should actually happen when I
execute this and I running into certain
conditions and one of the responses that
I have is this response 200 where my is
essentially a success saying is this
this is my CPU info one of the things
that we have done in the specification
is also we integrated something called
an operation ID this is a feature that
is part of the public domain tool that
we actually use to convert this
specification to a Python program or any
other program that now census is
developed me or spit out a template for
a function that's located in the CPU
directory but the function is called get
processor name so this is I have
implicitly included now a namespace into
the specification and now it's up to the
developer to implement that get
processor name function naturally if you
use a Java program you do this in Java
if you do this in Python you
in Python so we can do this for many
other things and then one of the things
that we really need to at the end is
this is we actually have a noun as part
of our rest definition you know what are
we actually storing and in our case we
have the CPU that for example has a
model and one of the model for example
we put in the string another would be
the value for the CPU value now the the
fascinating part about this once you
actually write this we are utilizing for
example a connection the software
connection and it spits out when you
read in in for example this line ape up
at API CPU Tamil this is where ml file
is being written a full-fledged rest
service so this means that this ten
lines of code and the ml specification I
have there I have to find a rest service
this now becomes super useful if I am
specifying a document that says okay you
know this is my standard that I would
like to everybody have follow in my
company or in NIST or in my university I
follow that and then I'm spitting out
with 15 lines of code arrest service and
this not only can I do this with one
service such a soupy you example but I
can do this with any service that I
specify and so so therefore I have a
scalable framework for defining any
interface to any service that I want to
do now one of the things that we have
actually done is is we have actually
leveraged from our previous work from
cloudmesh which has its own architecture
and the architecture is very simple as a
layered architecture where we leverage
platform-as-a-service
HPC obstructions containers and
infrastructure as a service and exposes
to a cloud mesh client the cloud mesh
client is our API in Python that exposes
all of these services to applies on API
and I don't claim that we have completed
that implementation that's naturally an
academic project but we can make that
more say more stable in case there is
some vicious being formed this is I
would like to see this or that or the
other and then we can integrate this we
used to also have a cloud mesh portal
that integrated this whole thing as a
portal but we no longer support that
because we found the client API so
useful and V means me as I made the
decision at one point I don't have the
time to develop to pol flask and Jango
portals it's just too much time on our
hands we need to be focusing on the bare
stuff that provides functionality so sue
cloudmesh we can now integrate cloud
mesh in these operations IDs that I've
actually showcased you so this means I
can now technically say this is a start
up a cluster in for example San Diego
through me defining an interface and the
interface is arrested URL basically and
through the URL I can actually start an
entire cluster in San Diego just ten no
it's there's no problem I can do the
same thing on Amazon or Google if I were
to be facilitating these interfaces so
why is this also useful is this is a via
ferrata already earlier about the
continuous integration so we can
naturally do an deployment obstruction
and that's what we need to do next this
is we can not only develop these
services but we need to be deploying
them onto a real hardware and software
so what we then can do is we can use the
github publish the stuff there use maybe
ansible share for heat and put some data
on this to create deployments on
different architectures to verify if
these services are compatible on all of
these infrastructures good example this
is typically people use a zoo and Amazon
and so this way we can verify if our
services were run on BOS and what
performance hits - you get when you are
using the one or the other service
this can then integrate integrate adorn
this has been integrated in our
development for the NIST document where
we did the design decision on the very
top which is our volume we derived from
the volume through our cloud mesh
scripting a specification and the
deployment that we then executed on data
and then we tried them out so that we
can verify if that entire process of
defining these services does work here
is an example and I apologize for the
small picture so I may have to skip this
I'm not sure if you can read it though
it's difficult for me to to see but this
is an boot process and I will be going
into this a little bit later so this is
just a virtual machine but it could also
be applied to a docker container if we
simply say this is select me a
particular resource on that resource I
would really like to build a machine or
I need to get an image I need to get a
flavor I need to start this thing up I
need to get a something back but I can
also do this on another cloud and the
the problem is is is that we need to be
sometimes replicating these on other
clouds because I'm about multi cloud
environments I'm not only about Amazon
or zoo I'm about all of them so in order
for us to do this is we have to then
developed our provisioning activities
and these provisionary activities then
for example integrate how do you select
the cluster you know what do you
actually want to have CPU memory what
software would like to have what suffer
would you like to deploy and so we
staged that's such an specification onto
that particular infrastructure this was
all fairly theoretical and I not sure
how many pages that this document has
because they are formulating it
differently I would guess it's 120 years
or something in that direction
it's a fairly you've been a long
document but it has limitations and the
limitations can be found by you you can
contribute to this and then we can make
suggestions from this to improve upon it
so I would like to get to this example
and the example is the same problem that
our colleague from earlier from Ball
State faced and we have these students
from biology from the Education
Department that may actually study data
science as their topic now if you know
about what it actually takes to put a
virtual machine on on Amazon or on a zoo
you typically say oh you said GUI you
know everything is being done through a
GUI but I'm dealing with a thousand
virtual machines how do you do this
visit GUI you know this is not not that
scalable so I need to be figuring out
how do I actually teach them how to do
that and so the best way we found is as
we develop our own tool from the command
line that actually is able to do
something in that direction or works
towards that direction so what we can
communicate to the students is we can
give them actually a configuration file
for the class or for their project or
for their problem and we define this
wisdom this takes me power five minutes
to do while discussing the needs with
the students or the faculty members that
actually do this and then I essentially
says it's okay what infrastructure would
you like to have so on which cloud would
you like to host this oh but do you want
to have your virtual machine beam butand
booted and so what I can essentially say
this is okay set the cloud to the cloud
of a particular name and the names are
for example Amazon Google or whatever
other things you do and you can specify
your own names you could call this green
eggs and ham if you want but you know or
something more useful like my
transportation problem cloud or
something like this so the next thing is
this is
when you look at the Python API to boot
this thing up you will find that you
have to deal with security groups you
have to deal with keys that you may have
on your local machine and stuff like
this and if you have a key on your local
machine the only thing that you have to
do with us is actually saying CMS VM
Buddha and it boots up the virtual
machine
I've actually here slight error is
actually CMS VM SSH used to have a login
but I've replaced this with SSH so in
case you want to manage the virtual
machine you can say CMS VM delete as you
see there's no specification of any name
for the virtual machine which is for the
user completely unimportant right
because he wants to have a virtual
machine this is a one-off example so
cloudmesh saves lay in the name of the
last started virtual machine and I can
actually do this all these commands
without me remembering that name a
completely unimportant for me I can
naturally specify the name as a
parameter to any one of these things in
case I have multiple ones not only that
as this is I can actually put in host
names based on bracket notation so let's
assume I want to define the machines
Gregor one to Gregor thousand I don't
have to type in thousand things like
this I simply say this is CM VM boot
Gregor bracket open one - thousand when
opens up a thousand virtual machines so
and there's a color issue the first one
was supposed to be AWS so CMS said cloud
equal to AWS how do you boot nan now on
Amazon well simple CMS VM boot now you
set the cloud to OpenStack which we have
access to a cloud that has OpenStack now
the question becomes to a student how do
you boot a virtual machine on OpenStack
well oh if I already do a CMS via mood
or llamas on a ship is that doing the
same thing on OpenStack so we do the
same thing I know it's like now I switch
the cloud
to Azure and how do I know how to start
a virtual machine well CMS via mood so I
can remember CMS VM boot well I can't
remember anything else anyways and this
looks up in your ml file the default
images that you would like to use and if
you have made very good experience with
this because you know our times you know
the Amazon Cloud went down so we
switched to an azure cloud or the
OpenStack cloud was not available and we
switched to an Amazon Cloud so there's
no excuse anymore for the students not
to do their homework because we can say
this is the cloud if the cloud goes down
please go to another cloud I don't know
how to do this well how about a CMS said
cloud equal Azure and n CMS reboot and
you know now I've eliminated 70% of our
homework problems so this is this is
fantastic right so I can actually do
this further and we used to actually
have two years or three years ago a
really cool framework that actually did
this but we haven't so far implemented
this into the new version of cloud mesh
but we want to for example host now and
Hadoop cluster which we need for big
data analysis as part of the Big Data
reference architecture to demonstrate
that we can actually deploy for example
our do so how would we
how did we do that or how would we do
that so we did that in the past to say
okay select me in the infrastructure on
which I would like to host at that
particular Hadoop cluster I say CMS set
cloud equal OpenStack and then I simply
say this is OK
create me the cluster where I have the
name Hadoop cluster I get 10 nodes and I
have the service I do and then I simply
say CMS cluster deploy with that name of
the Hadoop cluster and it deploys that
thing for you on that particular cloud
so again this is not implemented this
used to be implemented so we hope that
the current generation of students for
this semester may be able to do
something in that direction more on
cloudmesh I would
to focus a little bit more on the I
would like to go a little bit away from
the NIST representation towards the
cloudmesh representation because when
did I start with cloud exactly 10 years
ago so that's when OpenStack wasn't yet
invented and we still had eucalyptus and
all kinds of other stuff and some of
these lessons that we have here is based
on that experience that we have over 10
years of running multi cloud
environments so we have already
identified that we can easily managed
virtual machines but we can as well
manage containers or interface with
kubernetes clusters if you savant
because if you for example want to say
this is deploy me a cluster with 10
nodes we could be for example doing this
was for example kubernetes control
commands and hide them and then to cloud
mesh so that's really really convenient
for us to do we also need to be
interesting hybrid clouds this means
we not only have a cloud and Amazon but
also maybe my local computer or a cloud
on-premise this which we are integrating
and this is the multi cloud stuff that
we already pointed out why would we do
this we have capacity technology and and
integration Federation and robot
robustness if you take a look at this
and this picture this makes it pretty
clear in multi cloud environments as
students sometimes get a free tier and
what we can essentially do is is we can
combine all the free tiers to one so as
a cool capacity and this is actually a
good story because I had one student
that actually refused to shut down his
virtual machines on a cloud and within
two weeks he used 20,000 compute CPU
hours while the entire calculation was
irrelevant he used up the entire the
entire allocation for the entire class
and he refused
you shut his virtual machines down and
so we no longer do that so we just don't
buy any hours anymore we simply says is
take the free stuff if you don't get get
the free stuff and no to bad technology
robustness naturally when one cloud goes
down we can move to another and we can
leverage services from different clouds
with each other and this is important
for the big data reference architecture
because we may have services that are
hosted on one cloud but not offered on
another cloud but for us as data
scientists doesn't really make a
difference which cloud we have you want
to have the functionality so naturally
we can integrate things such as priced
and transparent the availability
capacity and vendor login as parameters
to the motivation why we are actually
doing that and we need to manage this in
some kind of brokerage fashion so we
start now integrating a project that we
call cloud my frugal where we maybe find
more cheap resources on data and compute
and so this way you may want to move
your data and to cheaper tea at a
particular period of time or something
in that direction one of the things that
we found actually is pretty pretty cool
too is this is we have developed as part
of NIST the concept of or actually as
part of cloud mesh and then integrated
this in internists the concept of
virtual directories at times you may
wonder host your data and multiple
services depending on where your
analytic services are running you may
have to duplicate the data or so so that
you can start up the services on that
particular cloud or you don't have
enough resources such as for example our
students they get the free tier and they
can store that much you know and so what
we did is this is we created a virtual
directory in which we have a directory
name and in that we have a file being
represented and that file points to the
appropriate cloud
but when the student uses this on the
local computer and simply says fetch me
or list me that particular file that
goes out to the cloud fetcher says over
to the local machine and then you see
this on just as a local directory
naturally if the if the internet goes
down you're out we didn't build in any
fault tolerance and so forth in but this
is an easy student project to enhance
the same thing we did with the virtual
cluster so technically we can actually
do an IP address as the cluster and we
can move that into a virtual cluster and
that virtual cluster could be hosted
anywhere and we can do virtual machines
or containers or whatever I think you
want to do and so this doesn't have to
be just a virtual machine it can also be
a real computer additional features that
we are looking into this is for example
obstructions for compute tasks function
data the XS for example we I put you a
command shell shell and line for that
reason I've pointed out away earlier in
the morning that we have developed
something called CMD 5 which is a Python
package that not only allows you to do
an arc V but it actually runs a shell
and you can switch between shell and
command-line invocation so you can have
a shell that actually stores the status
but also command-line so this way we can
for example say CMS set cloud equal to
Amazon and the next time I invoke that
particular command it actually is doing
this and then you can invoke the shell
which functions just like a matlab
function and so there's a whole bunch of
commands that we can do you can do
manuals and scripts you can list flavors
and set clouds and so forth you can list
the image and one of the things that
this is if you go to Amazon you for
example find 94 thousand images on
Amazon that takes quite a while to
download and mine if you would really
like to do this like an academic like I
do you know you may actually upload your
own images but you know we
actually my 94,000 ma just you know but
but okay so this is what we do and one
of the things this is we have a local
[ __ ] database and our computers stored
where the data is being downloaded and
so while it may take you 45 minutes to
maybe download that particular data said
in if you have it in the database and
mine it in the database you have it in
two seconds so this is really super cool
and especially when we are talking about
the thousand virtual machines that you
now need to be modifying you don't have
to go out for every single machine if
you don't want to have just the status
but want to have some information about
that particular machine such as which
operating system runs on the shell
commands we can switch color on and off
you can switch refresh on we have a
variable management and we have a
configuration file management that we
have included so that you can easily set
for example CMS a cloud equal AWS we
have help and then we also have or used
to have this is not yet supported in our
current version high performance
computing interfaces where you can
actually run batch jobs and this is
becoming important because they are
batch queues exposed in Amazon and so
forth so how do we do this
well we install this currently because
this is a developer thing so we have
with no own installer that goes out and
downloads like seven eight repositories
and was a one line command students can
now specify the installation capability
and it's very easy to to install
naturally because Jupiter notebooks are
kind of popular all of this stuff can be
integrated in a jupiter notebooks so you
can start virtual machines from
cloudmesh straight in your jupiter
notebooks not only that you can actually
do this on coop lab and there was a
discussion earlier today is can I
install something yes you can install
this because this is a Python package so
you can install it the database may not
be run but you still can can start these
things
here's a an example on how we for
example have an Abe API for Python that
you could be running on coop net or any
other Jupiter notebook as you see is
this as I have a provider the name is
chameleon cloud give me the flavors
printer flavors and the same same thing
we actually have four four images and
virtual machines so this is super easy
to use this one I cannot display you any
more because I'm out of time but this is
essentially the same thing as our soupy
you example here we just take an example
that uses k-means as an AI services and
we take we leverage scikit-learn as one
of its underlying mechanisms for
developing the operation ID and you find
a lot of information on our github page
and again this presentation will be made
available to you on my web page or on
the PI data web page so that you can
figure out all these links and spend
hours and hours of browsing but if you
want to spend less hours browsing you
can contact me directly so there is no
problem with this and we have a certain
other prototype things such as for
example a workflow system or how do you
get for example access to a cluster that
has GPU machines and and stuff like this
and the elastic revenues and how do you
integrate for example work shift and we
do actually have academic papers and I
don't require you to read them for you
getting a good grade so you already
passed because you no one has actually
left the room yet so I'm really thankful
for this and with this I would like to
close the presentation so there's some
questions on the slider right there if
you wouldn't mind yeah I think we can go
a couple extra minutes here to let you
cover that I need to look at this well
open API is really yes somewhat similar
but
into it's based on llamo and so it it is
specialized for developing services and
if you could read the question so the
question is is open API similar to
interface definition language from ages
past and the difference I actually see
is open API is focused entirely on the
rest services and is a specification in
Yama lor JSON format and thus easily
portable does this tell you how you
should set up an enterprise data
architecture no that is up to you guys
to define what NIST simply says is there
these components that could be utilized
as part of your architecture so you will
have to pick and choose the ones that
apply to you because NIST would not be
allowed to simply say this is or this is
how the architecture must look like but
it says it could look like and then does
it connect all the legacy systems and
data the architecture does not make any
exclusion of that so that is up to the
developer to make sure that this is
integrated I don't know informatica and
mule soft so I don't know what these
systems are so my apologies for for the
not knowledge so I can't answer that
question maybe we can keep this question
here so that the person who has this
question can educate me and then I can
comment on this how do students pay or
get charged for all the cloud stuff
there only I these days I only give them
on the mandate to use the free tier for
students on any of the clouds because of
my bad experience I had was this other
student and I can't control the other
students if there's one bad apple in
there as bad for everybody and so I have
unfortunately changed my model to use
only the free tier so how enterprise may
be charged if I would be an enterprise I
may actually
focus on one cloud or two clouds because
the cost savings worth switching from
one to another cloud at runtime or
during the program development could be
substantial so they're dependent on what
services you'd need so so certainly this
is different but cloudmesh doesn't make
any any assumptions about that this this
restriction comes from me so how do you
deal with identity and secrets to access
the services you deploy with the cloud
mesh tool right now the cloud mesh tool
is a client to all the identity
management is being done on my laptop
and each one would have to have its own
credentials to for example go into the
clouds and that's how I switch between
them so that's part of that llamo file
but it could be integrated into some
other services such as for example an
existing cloud service doesn't just tell
you how you should Oh
so yeah the informatica and we all soft
can you maybe elaborate what that is
maybe I know of yeah I guess I'm I'm
blessed being an academic and don't have
to know that particular - or these
things and maybe I'm not blessed but I
have to admit ignorance here that I
actually don't know these tools I think
I think you should must so I should
probably learn about this and then I may
be able to answer that particular
question yeah
[Music]